Õpetaja: Nämähän ovat minkäkin nykyinen pilvesymboli ja punainen mummukänä
Õpetaja: Paljon mötyä. Ei
Õpetaja: minkin viidennessä minuutinen pause, että kun järkeä ja tule Siellä kohta opereerima. Pannaan pauseille aikaisemmin. On se, että kun pause takaisin tulee, niin minä panen alatti ne kortin.
Õpetaja: Okei, Mitä läks? Katumaan? Vaan video Yksi ja taikka trendartamaan ja trendertämään. Onko kumpakin saa nähdä kuin molemmat trenertaan
Õpetaja: Siis Mistä videoteekan veel teemme?
Õpetaja: Me teemme videotekaan niimoodi iga Päivä saa sellaista videoista. Subtiitrit. Missä tekst? Lähde päälle kuin nykyinen tekstifile
Õpetaja: Mitä me ensimmäisen groupilla tekimme? Minä tekin Cloudistuksen Skillin pohjimässä? Missä siis Ytrevät heiää. Minä annan sulle tekstifaili. Missä on video Zoomivideo Transcription.
Õpetaja: Koko sisukohort. Koska videominuutit päällä, Kun pitäisi jakaa.
Õpetaja: Kaikki teemat, mistä me läpi Käymme ja metsät. Minkinsuiset materiaalit.
Õpetaja: Mitä on siis suht jääperäistä ja kenasti juures, kun minkin teemana huvita hiljaamisesta, panen repossa juurille se sama projekti, Mitä me teemme,
Õpetaja: on siis? Saatu kiire ylävaltaan erinomaisissa teematissa. Mitä me olemme käsittäneet? Ja kun vajaa ooitsijoita Ylässä eikä vastaavat itse asiat, minä Olen itse kodissa pärjissä. Minulla Ei ole mitään veits taastata ja timmitä. Ja minä sain. Arvan, että
Õpetaja: vähän videoita. Minkälaiset asiat olemassa siis sammu Velkaukemalla minna. Noutpukellen. Olette katsottanut käsitystä.
Õpetaja: Mitä,
Õpetaja: okei? Väga hea platvorm. Se on siis googlen. Oma notebook lemmiin. Erisyys on se, että se on Sellainen kohta. Kun sinä saa visattu, Mistä olisi Dokumentit, on, että Pdfit ovat World Filet,
Õpetaja: Md Failit Mitä me emme katsoimme siinä
Õpetaja: isänä kikitäärää, Vaan kun semminkin. Kaksikymmentä dokumenttia missäännessä. Sinä taida kikkitä, että mitä sinä selviäisi Konkreettisella hetkellä, kun tahat kiisena ja siis sinä saat siellä chat yöltä. Okei, räikeimminkin
Õpetaja: Muta. Next. Mind map, teemat ja kauppa Erää. Kuin Tässä ei ole minkäänlaissa siellä on podcast.
Õpetaja: Jos kaksi ensimmäistä jäpivät, sitten Saat itsekin nivelita ja itsekin jo bluginakovima, elikkä mikrofon.
Õpetaja: Se on hieno kysymys. Missä kysyi Vastus minulle
Õpetaja: videokokku. Päris päris hea
Õpetaja: Minun möntäni on Se, että me saamme asiaa tehdä, kun maksimaaliset arakasvat ne teemat ja materiaalit mistään läpi käymään natukene. Näemme vaivaa, että tekin Tätä
Õpetaja: lyhemmät viitsamat Seitittävää ja kokku röttikkomat ja jopa illustrad.
Õpetaja: Me voisimme tainnut minä yksin tai jään sitä tekemään pikemmin, että puhtaasti.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies, milloin se Zoomin video. Elää yhtä kuin rävä. Kyllä, jakaa vaan materailee. Vajaan
Õpetaja: tehdään paljon. Seitti tai me teemme väessan läpi ja proovimme vaan Se Välillä tulee vain. Ja
Õpetaja: minä arvanan, että me viksimme sitä tehdä.
Õpetaja: Se on täysin tavallinen tasoittokontto. Siellä onkin sellainen konkson kaa, että kahdenneljän tunnin perässä On
Õpetaja: kaikkia niitä asioita, mitä minä näyttänyt, kun et saa tehdä Vaan arvoisa.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme.
Õpetaja: Screenshare on minulla just aina.
Õpetaja: Teemme siis lahti, Telj Jollakin tavalla edes tarttamaan
Õpetaja: siis ensimmäinen asia, millä jonka me voisi tekeillä. On? Se että
Õpetaja: Arvoisa.
Õpetaja: No Arvoisa Mikäli on
Õpetaja: ensinnäkinnontrollerade Försökerlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign tämä maltillinen Asia, joka pikemminkin pikemmin voi väljoittaa
Õpetaja: taustalla. Mistä Db onkin siis se, että on siis mailtu jaava ja gotlinen kirjoittamiseksi?
Õpetaja: Meillä on eräti tuotteita, Richard intelligei Ultimate.
Õpetaja: No se ei, Kyllä, Se on yksi reilu Kreikan vastuu ja se natukene onkin viipinarentus eli nykytootannon Webstad
Õpetaja: Sata niin fronti, Kuinka jaavaajaksi? Sitten saat Kyllä, ennen kuin ei ole vaja eräille
Õpetaja: no teiselta päris krikkeinä, kun ei toeta absoluuttiset krikkeita. Richard,
Õpetaja: teistä tuotteet K jaoks. Terve rotuneet. Chatbrains on siis heettävät
Õpetaja: tasullinen. Tuo tämä,
Õpetaja: kun te aktiveeritte siellä ultimateissa. Kelat ja vilaatin. Ei tajua, että näitä päikkäiset asiat Mitä tässä toimivat? Minulla on koko ajan ültimeid
Õpetaja: kuin minulla ei ole isäkasutan. Kata. Kiivitti, että kun minulla ei ole siis nuuskäs, kun viisitoista Kuusi maksima töissä kuitenkin
Õpetaja: koko se. Oaj verkkoa, että sinä saat Progata siellä vähän monisat ja mukavaa alkaa kuitenkin vähemmäksi aikaa. Se klöpistäminen.
Õpetaja: Miksi Mennään peaks ostamaan Ultimatey.
Õpetaja: Seisivät, kun hoidavat.
Õpetaja: Minun aina on parin näillä sellaiset.
Õpetaja: Kun minä tuttuisin teman kanssa, siis minä panin tähele. Jopa Microsoft tehnyt oman. Age Missä on siis Chromy, Basil Browser
Õpetaja: ja siis arentajana. Minä olen esimerkiksi minua enää,
Õpetaja: että kun esimerkiksi tehkää meille veebilehtäkin on Kysymys, mitä tuettamaan. No, mistä me rääkinnan minun piiii
Õpetaja: android. Mis versioinnit iphone Millä. Me räägimme Chromin Suojan sukuna safari, suojan sukuinen ja
Õpetaja: brauserit Tästä päätisi toettamaan ja se on prosentin talvivaatteissa näitä.
Õpetaja: Internet Explorer, maailmas. Statistika, joilla on kasutaja täpset eli kaksi prosenttia tai enää kaksi prosenttia, Että kolme erävaltaa. Ei, ei
Õpetaja: noin kaksikymmentä prosenttia maailmalla. Ihmisellä oli osuutta paikalla määrin kuin paljoa sitten takaisin ja ja
Õpetaja: luomulikuttaa. Ja klienta on Valitettavaa, että Kikka peab toettamaan satakahdeksan.
Õpetaja: Ja siis onkin se minun aina Toxissa alkusaikaan. Minä uskon, että miksi. Miksi Ei, siinä on
Õpetaja: minua muutenkin. Sain vielä rohkeampia millin inimeä näitä. Olen siis, kun minä näkin. Esimerkiksi googeltaan.
Õpetaja: No Google. Taas Näin sen
Õpetaja: Tämä on siis Google. Tässä nimen, että siellä oli tietysti homepage. Til Www Netti punkt. Jopa klöbistä sitten
Õpetaja: ja kirjoitan sinne Google kirjoittamaan. Mitä olette itse, arvoisa herra puhemies
Õpetaja: normaalisesta Tylässä aadressin, että siellä itse sanaa ja
Õpetaja: on näitä inhimillisiä. Velvoitakin sikäli. Otetaanko omana? Kun ainoassa
Õpetaja: minulla on natukene saattanut Kai minulla on minkit Nupu massalamemaria, että Can Sees
Õpetaja: Browseries. Katsotaan Nature Shortcut. Missä Intelligace ja yksi tappavammin. Se, että
Õpetaja: työllisyys on se, että kun sinä Koska sitä on Selectat It Sunaa.
Õpetaja: Browseries on Control Kaksi V. On se, että Paned Täp kiinni.
Õpetaja: Sen Maksamme kättä. Entäs kohta? Tässä on minkä lehdelle. Rekaan kirjoittaa. Ja eriti kun se on Minkälainen suuri tekstiboks? Koska on paljon tekstiä kirjoitettu.
Õpetaja: Sehän minun kippuu olemaan. Niimoodi onkin. Jopa kirjoitat. Minkä Tässä vaiheessa. Minkä avastat? Sanon vain, että tyksu ylessä lät. Siellä teirit enää koetalle siniseksi.
Õpetaja: Okei, no kuues te nyt lahti. Tätäkään. Ole siellä Lopuksi kät kättä seisomaan uusi esi
Õpetaja: muuttumaan. Oliko varsinainen jalasella? Mutta lähme. Tässä Ei, sain. Minä luotan, että Tecttä
Õpetaja: nyt ensimmäinen asia, mitä voisi tehdä.
Õpetaja: Mitä minä, Demoharu. Missä meille tekin.
Õpetaja: Miksi minä pian selväksi tekemään äramejaama. Miksi,
Õpetaja: arvoisa herra puhemies?
Õpetaja: Checkout on siis se sana, millä saa mennä, siis. Kittis on se lina sana. Taustalla onkin. Kun tehdään
Õpetaja: olisi parempi näitä. Minä olen Master Reveal. Kun minä teen näitä. Minecraa Feb Seitsemän päivällä. Checkout
Õpetaja: siis taustalla näyttää. Käyvitys niukken ja käskii
Õpetaja: Checkout feb seitsemän ja litsaamaton. Ja vaikka. Se onkin, Se että saatte aroma minkinsukuiset Lahentuisivat
Õpetaja: taustalla toimittavat. Minä saan sitä samaa asiaa lyhentänyt. Mittavaa että Minä en löydä naivan Vaattakaan. Minä lähden koiraa. Ytlen lähen takaisin Master Rivlle. Pansin Master Rivale,
Õpetaja: Kun minä otan terminaalin, tein terminaalin prompteamissa. Windows kuin minä. Nyt panen siellä sama Gasu.
Õpetaja: Minä tiedän missä yllättäen ja olikin Feb Seitsemän. Kun minä nyt väitan. Enter
Õpetaja: siis taustalla käivittyisi Kitty Cash programmies Näissä seitsemäs ne nupput. Mitä te klöpistä? Missä on Kittikä
Õpetaja: meitä On Tehty kasut täällä. User interfaceilla, että kasut täällä on tehty mukavaksi. Kun te lähette nyt arennetussa työlle, siis te näette niitä. Vanakooli Renttäisi, Eikä sitä riittävät. Niin minä tee
Õpetaja: Tunnistaneet nuppana ja sellaisella. Kun tämä terminalaatteja sinne pannaan misto, Niitä on vähän eräs.
Õpetaja: Olen kutsuneet käsuria venteteks käsillä ja vennät.
Õpetaja: No, tavalliset ovat. Minulla on arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Olikin käsuriää värk. Olikin se, että vaataatte eräs mis failit ovat tehneet kuskil mihinkin Suvailissa ja muuta tuossa rohelina.
Õpetaja: Tekin uudet rajat. Värvitämme Teillä natukene materiaalia. Mitä Koti En ole rääkinyt, kun meillä on? Yksi tasullinen kurssus online kurssissa. Missä on teillä kättä saatava ja saatte tehdä sen Conflines. Jos olemassa
Õpetaja: vaikka sammut ja opettaa kaikkia näitä show parisaste
Õpetaja: ja miksi minäkin tekemään. On se, että minä olen nyt alkan vaikselt viskamaan teillä sinne. Slack, linkkiä Palun vaatekin. Sedaa ja tuota ja kolmantena syvennetään mitä me, Voimme niitä taisata jarruttaa, jotka pitäisi
Õpetaja: missään hetken seisää. Seitsemän.
Õpetaja: Joo, up to date.
Õpetaja: Ytpäevät, että nämä frontain tai index htmilis on muuta modify.
Õpetaja: No, se onkin se samanlaiseen.
Õpetaja: Sitä samaa kuin visuaalset,
Õpetaja: joka on tämmöinen vanasti, kun ei ollut ikään kuin kasutaja. Liitän sieltä Siis Vennat Paniikkinimet ajaa. Minulla on frontend Ind Indexissä. Muuta. Nyt minä siellä rakoin miettimään enää
Õpetaja: sekä Niimoodi niin teetisitte komitti lahti Vaatekassa teillä on Näette koko Ajan muutatte se
Õpetaja: ja siis onkin monet asiat. Mitä te pidätte teatamaankaan se millään? Te pidätte tulemaan kohdan sijaan ja elke voi olla aravisat Tai Roll Backi tai muuta takaisin. Kun minä teen siellä tykkän ridan
Õpetaja: tyhjän Ritan kulkee kun minä peräänkuulut tulen siellä päällä.
Õpetaja: Siellä Ylä Kaavailematikymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemänkymmentäseitsemän Worlback.
Õpetaja: Muuta
Õpetaja: kun minä olisin tahtonut sitä työtä, en täällä kuhunkin panna. Siis Minä pääsin siihen Kirjoittamaan. Minkä sanomia tai muut sen indeksit hakataan meillä tekin. Ja siis ärakoon miettimään valikkoja.
Õpetaja: Missä intressant tehdään Sellaisista kuin mittareista.
Õpetaja: No, otan sen fronten jälleen kun nyt tasokin lahti. Tähän,
Õpetaja: vaikka Minä nyt ensin minä Lähden sieltä Feb. Seitsemältä. Mitä te kaiken päälle päätisitte tekemään, Että se tulee järkimään ja rääkisin meille Fetchista, kun vaatai Peikeltyisi tai ei muuta mitte mitäkin.
Õpetaja: Kun siitä kittöristä visuaalisesta asiasta ainut Peikeltävä Missä toimivapää me olisivat?
Õpetaja: Ja minä teen. Nyt on se että Pannaan Master I päälle. Teen checkout.
Õpetaja: Nyt on nimelite. Nyt on se punaisen joinen värkki. Näette siellä Tahflin päin. Minä. Entä että Yksikin? Mutatvuuspilvä
Õpetaja: Ja vastuupiteet eivät toimu ilmaa nuppaklöpistämättä.
Õpetaja: Kun minä kustutan, ära näittää ahaa. Te möhäsiatistus ei kaa näitten sieltä Resentit Missä koko ajan näyttävät Siinä on jube tyyty elukkaassa, kun taakse koko ajan nähä siinä alle Ainut lokalit sekatusta kun te teette siellä harumajandussä sitten ylävältä lahteen ja vetätte Hammasrattaa
Õpetaja: siis. Siinä on olemassa show actions Recent Franchise. Minä otan
Õpetaja: siellä. Ei ole ylitse mitään. Mingit pointteja Testaataan siis, kun Tes korta lähtee.
Õpetaja: Minä otan sen linnuksen vielä taakse kaasella viime kaudella niin kuin isossa
Õpetaja: Niin, että nimetin paljon. Puhtaammissa risän Taikka koko ajan. Ette hyppaamaan. Minä Vihkan sieltä niin paljon kuin se vielä turin. Teit. Minä Olin selän
Õpetaja: koko ajan. Minä tahan vajuttaa siihen, että hyppää prissentti vielä. Minä en tiedä, miksi haluaisi vielä olemaan Joko näyttävät, kun sinä olet kuitenkin kolanut. Ja minä en tiedä.
Õpetaja: Minä Nyt kustutan. Ära. Ytan siellä valtakunnassa. Minä Ymmärrän, Fape. Seitsemän delete
Õpetaja: kustuttanut siellä siitä lokaalia Tärä. Vaikka kustannä ei kustutan.
Õpetaja: Track Branche Remote Origin Track Branche
Õpetaja: Mukavaa että sitkaa vajuttaa tai Nuppu Praegu linnukkelan myötä. Olen saanut alatti. Käsitsi tehdä kustutetaan ja tehdä siitä altsakaan. Valita Samat Valikot sitten Paremman Klöksykään
Õpetaja: juttelevat näistä samoista asioista Mitmes kohas toimetetaan.
Õpetaja: Näyttäisin ylävalon kellukänä. Sitten vielä näitä samun sanomia vaivatta missä on.
Õpetaja: Ja vaadake Mistä nyt kassa tahat sitä. Kutsut tätä, kun Minä Tekin sieltä Local Brancher kanssa. Tai kysyn kyllä.
Õpetaja: Se ei ole. Kysymys on pilves. Tämä on ihan ohtlikku.
Õpetaja: Äkki minua kokematta. Vajut sen, että kuu aikaa rämällä töitä on oma haru pilve pussiin. Lenan poläinen ja
Õpetaja: tulenhan Minäkin nämä kuuttakin. Että päris arendus, on minkä ei yhdeksän Kuusi kahdeksan
Õpetaja: kahdeksaa. Yhdeksän. Kahdeksan. Kuusi. Numbrit alkavat olemaan sama videi kunstuttamaan vähemmän lyhen. Korra Tulen minulle Se näkökää
Õpetaja: väliseikka. Sanotaan
Õpetaja: käsi mennä tekemään Ekstrakuljetuksia Siellä oli liittovalti oman karjäärin alkunsa, jossa lasta õhkuu neljään ihmisellä ja kuu ään
Õpetaja: nimetati sankti taasteta näet. Ilmeisesti voimaloissa vaalikaudella
Õpetaja: no. Naljakas oli yllä. Viskaiseksi. Olikin naljakas. Paras.
Õpetaja: No kuitenkin ilmi vai? Ei nairat?
Õpetaja: No niin, kustutan minä Nyt on se, että se on tihaa näitä. Kustuttisin. Teeb siellä, kun ei ole joutunut sellaisiin. Erätehan
Õpetaja: mitä minä tahan, kun teillä näytämme kohe kun tämä ytlipi, että se on tehty se Feb. Seitsemän pidä.
Õpetaja: Uskon minun. Katsottaisiin remoteilta, että nyt jäävät. Sitä Ei ole siellä. Kuidas on luo Tail remoteajalle.
Õpetaja: Kysyn, olen sen varassa, että Se peikäytyminen ei ole realäs
Õpetaja: Tai käy koko ajan Telitys ei käi koko ajan Vaatamassa, että kuule missään pilveessä. Missä pilveissä on Kuitenkin se Esilitsat Siis sinä oskat meitä Vaata, kun tätä
Õpetaja: niin alkaa. Nyt on se, että Master on Grammyra. Master on Ja
Õpetaja: siis Masterica. Te pääksette nyt tekemään nimetä, että te teitte klikki siellä päälle ja vajutatte. Panen siellä konsolisit lahteen, että saaks ne käske. Vaata, kun te lähdette nyt siellä Lokan masteri päälle ja pannatte update.
Õpetaja: Fiji ja Pulli. Se Pull on nyt päris käskoa tänään. Sinulla on työ siellä. Se lokal on Teidän Working. Näkut tai rektore Sin saa. Töötan,
Õpetaja: Mistä olette Checkoutit Ein? Teillä on ainakin Master Siellä enää
Õpetaja: se tähtää päris faily tai muuta Teille Työharus
Õpetaja: update. Hyväksyisi tekemään kaksi käskona ja tekin Fetchei
Õpetaja: oikein teki siellä niin kuin yhäkään sukaan erää, joka teki pulligaationsa.
Õpetaja: Vähän Fancy ruinia
Õpetaja: Isikys sieltä käskuun Pruunia teana. Ja kun minä tiedänkin, että ummes Mitäkin tauolista Se on kumminkin pulliai. Se on
Õpetaja: teilliset. Pushan, poll.
Õpetaja: Siinä on oma nimi vanasta öljissäkin Pulkussa, joiden siellä on upiteit kuitenkin tehnyt
Õpetaja: voi olla
Õpetaja: mission. Skilled on. Skill on siis juhanteja? Mitä saa taas? Kasvatetaan. Juhan
Õpetaja: minulla on Tox. Teori materas kausta.
Õpetaja: Jotkut sitä näyttävät.
Õpetaja: Millisel teemalla. Sovit materiaaliluvaa näitten Cc struktuurien kanssa ei Mennään voitte vastusta enemmän kontrolli olemassa olevaa materiaaleja. Voitteko se? Jopa on olemassa samalla teemalla materiaalilla. Äkki siis lisääminkin uusi teema kuin siellä alla
Õpetaja: esityksen konteksti. Kun me olemme jäppinytystä ja kaamitamme sisältä oma selkeä Resti.
Õpetaja: Sissejuhatus, Visuaaliset skeemit kuultiin näitä päriselu analogia, tabelina. Järgmiset sammut stilireglitest bla bla bla Torocen Juhan
Õpetaja: sellainen File. Missä on succeskaustaisena kuin Cloud Skills.
Õpetaja: Ytlen Cloudslignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign täällä on Absoluuttisesti että He Tässä Panen Gold Grieps
Õpetaja: Minä Olen Muun Muassa. Skillit kaikki Meille, jotka ovat nimettäneet Skill tava, on pikemmin se, että kun he luo suppe materjali on sellainen Skillinimi ja minulle, kun meillä on paljon, Entä tehty skillessä? Siis leianat kiireet Nimet Ylässä on Skill
Õpetaja: Simme saanut. Etsitään miten sisulisen puolueenpäin vai näiden nimet näitten Scriptionit.
Õpetaja: Ja kun tsätit Ja vestät siellä mitäkin. Sovit itsekin öeltä luo. Supermateriaali Scriptionisti. Jopa näen vaan
Õpetaja: tykkänen skilkussa on mainittu sana luo u supermateriaali. Ilmeisesti Ciksi. Käivitetään nämä Skilli luo. U supermateriaali. Se on vaatimassa
Õpetaja: sopimateriaali. Nyt on pystyisi kysymään missä teemalla.
Õpetaja: Minä kysyn, mitä Te Jit Brunä No,
Õpetaja: on olemassa Hypermateriaalit. Mitä menee kaustat tekemään?
Õpetaja: Olemassa olevat materiaalit samalle teemalle, jolää kausta kipruun käsku Alkaa kontekstiin. Miksei vaalikon selkää? Bla bla, bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: No, se nyt on kyse. Mistä minä lupasin? Kun hän alkuisen sanoi, että. Onko tämä Aid ja Cloud? Koutikoid? Japä täältä
Õpetaja: Se on minun kysymykseni.
Õpetaja: Kyse Skill on olemassa.
Õpetaja: Olette samassa formaatissa Panna sinne talks kausta lisän sinne projektin juurde ikäväksi,
Õpetaja: Kun isä olen tehnyt arendusta ja genereerin Minkälaista syntääkseni teemalla Oppimateriaalia
Õpetaja: hellisti saatain ja totean minulle materiaalitapan läpi Tai siellä teoriamateriaalit. Minä olen mälättänyt, että
Õpetaja: missä täpsa tekikin Minä mäletan jopa vähemmän. Minulla on olemassa supermateriaali. Siellä kohta. Vaattelen, koska olen mitäkin. Siellä kohta tein ja vähän. Tule tämän kiireittäin meiltä.
Õpetaja: Missä ne ovatnoineja?
Õpetaja: No Nyt kuitenkin. Toivottavasti se on tehty Siis kun siellä klikitään päälle ja toksika ostaa elää
Õpetaja: vaille nimeä, että teki tämän uusi faila. Juuri tämä, Mitä, Wahe Intelligen
Õpetaja: reaktiivisuus on vähän natukene. Kannattavia. Ei saa aru, että se on mitään uutta siinä Hylsään Kun tämä projekti Päälle. Parem glöks Ja vaatamassa Reload From Disc.
Õpetaja: Tiedotus tuli. Brune Preview. Vaatai, missä on.
Õpetaja: Ei viittaa minki rääkin mennyt lahteen.
Õpetaja: Minä saisin. Sanoa, missä niitä sanoi
Õpetaja: Kun tehdään kirjaa selliseti, kun sinä tulet siihen ja vaatat
Õpetaja: ja niin on defineerita Oik. Oi, armastavaa. Miksi tekstin kuivu struktuurin?
Õpetaja: Sinun kuotiblokk siinä Se on kooti.
Õpetaja: Saman vuoti siellä Md Mark Town Formaatis
Õpetaja: Voimaan Elikkä, on aika paljon äratehtävää tekstiä.
Õpetaja: Visualiseeritaan erinevalt vaikka. Se mötä on sama että Celine Dext.
Õpetaja: Minä olin kuhu. Ikanä sanoa, kun pannaan
Õpetaja: samoin visualiseeritelt.
Õpetaja: Kd Blokk. Saat vain kopi. Tänne.
Õpetaja: Muka?
Õpetaja: Missä on? Kuitenkin parempia tänä päivänä, mitä tehdään materiaalilla,
Õpetaja: Että se sama asia.
Õpetaja: Voin ajatella, että kuulla
Õpetaja: selvästi interaktiina.
Õpetaja: Html Stilis materiaali.
Õpetaja: No, arvoisa
Õpetaja: niin,
Õpetaja: Unversion Files, tämä värvä on punainen.
Õpetaja: Mitä Se ei tähenda sitä, että kit. Se versi on eriminen. Kutakin jälki. Ja se pillvä. Kai lähde. Säteily, voima, pussilla kutakin Pillää.
Õpetaja: Kuinka siellä faili tekit? Kun isä luot uefaili New File to add to the Kid kanssa. Projektista. Jotain version. Se samaan,
Õpetaja: kun se Oken lähemöltä siis on mitu variantti? Yksi variantti on, että tulet siellä päällä.
Õpetaja: Otsin kitin käsut ja kit äätä
Õpetaja: kun. Me nyt panemme siellä äänviisistön Muuttuu roheliseksi sitten. Se on täiesti tuttikkaisuusfeil missä. On jälkikäteen
Õpetaja: nythän? Jälkipsetaan nyt. On võimalik faili koska, tuhat kortavaa tai minkä muuta kuin Se tämä kohta on ajaluku
Õpetaja: Norjissa pidetäänkin ne erilaiset saman kohta takaisin ja että ei jälki takaisin. Sinne Voi arvoisa okei ja
Õpetaja: tuli. Takaisin Kysyin Ad File to Kit. Se onkin se, että minä kysyin. Missä on Sellel Sellel värillä
Õpetaja: Ja se on vaiva. Märkättävä kitijuuras. Käypäin jukana Failen Kitty Ignor ja ystävät.
Õpetaja: Mielestäni automaattisesti ja verso Neilissa. Tämä ei ole kunnianhattakaksikymmentäseitsemänsataa.
Õpetaja: Vaikka se kittignor on nyt väkätähtis tööriist
Õpetaja: se sama punkt Ei Peaks olemaan osa projektista. Minulla on. Minkälaiset minun sätteeni? Missä minä teen? Ja info on sellaisissa kaustassa. Kuitenkin olemassa.
Õpetaja: Meillä on meeskonnassa. Meillä on ettevirassa sata arentaa, jotka siellä projektissa tööt ovat oma sättäjä. Meillä on oma. Se ei ole osa projektissa ja se onkin se kitting Nordon ilmailus. Koska me saamme ärat defineerit. Ära seta mitte
Õpetaja: reitti kaasa pane.
Õpetaja: Ceta. Ei ole jälki teha tai ei lähde joka piilevä mitkä Minkin valinnakaan.
Õpetaja: Siinä onkin ääneen, että se sama pun pitää olla,
Õpetaja: kun siellä elää kaustaalaisiin. Minun kustutan selvästi ära.
Õpetaja: Refresh. Minä en tiedä kuin Tässä on
Õpetaja: minä. Tässä on nyt tavallistarve. On niin Kit Kittignor Siis tuli siihen takaisin.
Õpetaja: Paneb järjest. Saattemin.
Õpetaja: Siis joku.
Õpetaja: Missä on projektiosa ja Mitä on tähtis teata? Meillä Kasvattamme yhteen ykköslahennuksen. Missä Kun isät ja Neili meillä? Kun kootiin välillä
Õpetaja: serverissä, siis serverit eivät täpipeat sitä samaa Tai genere eri isä.
Õpetaja: Automaattiset. Eli kun me juomme sinne maani, siis yksi kous. Missä me yhdellä hetkellä tahoimme, että ärat sitä mantti
Õpetaja: kaasana ja vetää.
Õpetaja: Tavalliset kittignodit ovat nämä projektina. On Jopa märksa mahukamat.
Õpetaja: Kuskil onkikaan. Kittignor nioilta
Õpetaja: Backendia on eräilti kittignore selkä kaarasta ja frontend ja Front Iat. Mitä Puolella Vaja se sama on no? Modules, se. Ei ole osa breaklist
Õpetaja: sehän. Lehditettäkseen se. Failit ylässä missä. Meillä on sen Kipruunde, koska linkinkaava viitenä siellä failisissa tekit.
Õpetaja: Oi jotenkin. Minkä artifaktein tyk? Tekijänä Joko Pam Palun Veganaan, kun panemme koko maailmalle nähtäväksi puun prykikastin Tyhjentämminä
Õpetaja: näiltä lähteistä materiaali.
Õpetaja: Oletteko pitänyt interaktiivinakaan? Minä en tiedä, missä siellä plikkeitä, vai mitä tehdään vaan
Õpetaja: olenemismateriaali Eikä teet saattaa olla, että se Ei vistä natukene.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa materiaali.
Õpetaja: Kun me olemme saaneet sen projektiksi, vaan lisää linkkiä Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies taipaa.
Õpetaja: Nyt täytyy sanoa sellaisia kausta Juuri on sen kipruun Hotel
Õpetaja: penselinen lahti. Se nyt autemell koot. Mitä me alkaamme? Kohden? Kohdan vaatamaan koko stiilitä, ja Alkaa kuin
Õpetaja: vaatisin, siis saa Wöyltäkään, että kuljet teise. Browser Is on saman leil.
Õpetaja: Ei ole aika hetkeä.
Õpetaja: Okei, Mitäkin on Puutu tähän? Tukee suojelta, että Kyllä Brunbrygikasti Tähentäminen enäämisellä.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies Microsoftille.
Õpetaja: Potilaat
Õpetaja: tuon pikemminkin erillisen Fontinkaan kaavaa, että nimetitte, vaikka olisiko tehdä skilloa, kun sinä selkitsevät keräävät palvelun arvosta Sen jälkeen, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: Että kun minä ikapäiväisesti soviksi, niin yksi ei taisi. Minulla ole sellaista kohta, Skill.
Õpetaja: Minä sovinkin siellä Sellises formaatissa ja kirjoitusajoja. Vaikka Se mitä Cloud Coat kuin
Õpetaja: paljut. Jopa kirjoittaneet, että Mtf eile vähän eilistäkin juhiset ja asiat peavat olemaan en nyt Eilistä pakanaman täällä.
Õpetaja: Emmekö me voimme välttämättä? Jos me teemme siis myöskin aika listat vimailuus, että
Õpetaja: minulla oli tytär, Piti ja teki kai vähän. Isä laittaa pukest sama Skilliin
Õpetaja: Md, vaan että sain paikkaan, missä Sisu voisi olla isänsä syypisin kyselessä. Yritin saada käy, kun aina, kun Suuret aasta rääkisivät ainut käsi. Mitä minä tean, on You will Fysiikasta, että meillä jää noin.
Õpetaja: Siis tytäröille. Kuljettaja vaan se on räkset koko ajan
Õpetaja: Minä odottaa. Minä olen kyllä tämän sainmäki tekimin. Ja kunhan sai selväksi. Chilli Willi.
Õpetaja: No, minä ymmärtänytkään että minä nyt minkä synnun voisi olla vaan viisaasin Etenee näyttää,
Õpetaja: kun ei saa tehdä paremman klöksukaa. Kit ad
Õpetaja: siis Minä olen saanut nämä tilitä siellä.
Õpetaja: Jos Arvoisa herra puhemies, Minä vaatan, koska Roll Backolä.
Õpetaja: Kun kokematta lisät mitä tahansa tai mitään siis roll back. Ei, unversions. File ei kustuttaa erää. Te liittäneet
Õpetaja: isäkin, Kun Siinä on minkit Failit. Mitä jälkiversioneerimissäkään siis lokal historia Ochronlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign
Õpetaja: Millä Mässä Mennään Se Indeksi Saattaa Meille
Õpetaja: Tänäiseksi Minä Olen Jopa Taastanut Roll Back Inut vaan siinä olivat tyhjät Rajat ja asiat olivat
Õpetaja: kun tähän lokal History Show historia.
Õpetaja: Mutta leija berinä vain hetkellä, koska minä olen sen toimettanut, että kutsutut kokematta minket faili ässä
Õpetaja: välisiäkin saa tehdä on se että, sinä olet koko katalogin väittäisin tulee, koko projekti päälle ja Ytelet kuulla näitä. Minulla lokaal historia.
Õpetaja: Nyt alkaa failita Kauppaa Sieltä kuitenkin eittämättä En mäleta. Kuin tässä saa. Kuitenkin saada on Faily
Õpetaja: missä ei ole verisoneerimisessä tekevät kun jälkiä.
Õpetaja: No, se on what you pay.
Õpetaja: Okei Japa Japaa tehkää. Siis. Tehkää siellä. Master, update
Õpetaja: siis te Olette täysin Samaa Joona äärellä kuin Minä ajattelen. Pääkö olemaan nyt. Ketkä, terämaailma
Õpetaja: Ja no
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies
Õpetaja: Aha,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies, Rekordin, kun
Õpetaja: arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Joukossa.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies, arvoisa puhemies, arvoisa Puhemies, Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Sillä Tavalla Mukava viedä.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies
Õpetaja: halvimmassa.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: Pohjois keinoja,
Õpetaja: arvoisa herra puhemies, Arvoisa herra puhemies
Õpetaja: tosuttaa kolken päällä ja minä ajan kurssin Veikkaan, että
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies ja
Õpetaja: nämä kaksi euroa,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies ei löytynyt.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies oli väärää. Proovida, meille että Se töötan.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies, Arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies
Õpetaja: arvoisa Puhemies,
Õpetaja: lävitse ja viemässä.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies, arvoisa Herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Suureltaisin minua.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies, arvoisa puhemies arvoisa Puhemies,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: klubinjohtajaa
Õpetaja: koviksi
Õpetaja: finansson.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies
Õpetaja: Sinänsä mainitsekin kuntaan kuuluu tälle, arvoisa herra puhemies, Siis kun nyt laitosin.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies, Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Mittana arvoisa niin, salvestus ja nup
Õpetaja: Minulla oli oppi. Se oli Screenshare Oli pause väl Viisitoista minuuttia. Tuossa keritään.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme erääseen.
Õpetaja: Saimme Rita kesällä trikkikää otsapää ja tuntuu, että teistä saarutitte sinne.
Õpetaja: Niin. Mielestäni taamisessa alusta onkin, se, Kun Te teette lahti Frontendistä Frontend kautta.
Õpetaja: Nyt esitys on se, että Frontein ja Back and Server tööttavat ylitse. Kun teillä ei ole siinä Stop nuppu koos number kahden, joka tyskin serve retkeilee tööt. Minä pidän panemaan Frontin.
Õpetaja: Siellä ei ole mitään fronteamista, niin kuin piisaa
Õpetaja: asia, Missä voisi Teata Frontendin puhu. On selinää, että vois ja Frontendissä on teknologiana kuin hot reload.
Õpetaja: Me voimme kootibaasissa tehdä Vaikka me emme pidä serverit itse uueesti käivittämään luksuspuolella. Sellainen, että iga korkua kooti kirjoittavat valmis siis käivittämään, jotta Saksa arvioi, että se taustalla toimii. Miksei Niin on, mutta Teoriaatkaa,
Õpetaja: kun minä olen Pannan täällä ensimmäisenä linkin kanssa. Mitä paras siis Voidaanko pikemmälti vaatamaan?
Õpetaja: Lähde Neutching Confluencist Missäännöständigheterlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign Pks Hublina
Õpetaja: Siellä on Mitto Space. Meillä on erääli. Vai liittää
Õpetaja: Kyllä, siellä. Itpllä siis. Siinä on
Õpetaja: yksi asia. Missä siinä on? On nail kursus vai It Car portal It Crafters kuolitus. Missä on cinematy, Punktit ja kauppa erätuot. Ja milläkö saa hakata oppimaan tarkkvara? Alennus Siis It Crafters programin jälkeen
Õpetaja: esimerkiksi pikemmät tehdä. Äkki Se on lisät osa pohjoismaissa.
Õpetaja: Yksi sprint on kaksi nädalaa, kuten oppilas Tai siis kun teki kaksi nädalaa. Minkä taisi jo
Õpetaja: täällä päällä. Kyllä, se kuolitus on. Teillä on kättä saatava ja te saatte. Vaata, materiaalit lisää. On Knowledge Pacl.
Õpetaja: Mitä minä tahaksin rääkida? On vatis Java Sorsweil.
Õpetaja: Panen jopa sellään linkin. Panen viiksitte sieltä. Vaata, että
Õpetaja: minä luotan. Linki, Guide Linki kiireiltä sinne.
Õpetaja: Nyt yksi vaikea konkurssi. Muitakin on kuitenkin selkitään, missä olisi sen lähtökohdat, kun me jaavaamme vaatimme sieltä
Õpetaja: Jaavaa möttäisi Meillä on Selina File Bank. Application. Se on nyt lähtökohta. Punk Jaava File
Õpetaja: on se, että meillä on Jaova Fail. Ja meillä on sellainen program kuin Java kompilator. Vanhasti piti käsitsi joä faili kauppa, isä käskä käivittämään, että. Hei, siinä on minun koot vaan teitä. Pai kootiksi.
Õpetaja: Miksi jaava Niin populaarne on, se että on tehnyt siihen lisälahennuksen
Õpetaja: Windowsilla Linuxilla mäkelä, Koffi keittiälä, tehneet eräiltiin. Programmeeritut masin
Õpetaja: on nykyään vahel. Yli Windows is on Jaova virtuaalimaisiin. Linuxis on Jaova virtuaalimaisiin ja siis mäkis on Jaova virtuaalimaisiin. Nyt Kun sinä tahan. Juoksuttaa tai
Õpetaja: koot ovat mitäkin taallista. Kahdeksaa numbrikauppaa noin litöhättä.
Õpetaja: Se on paitkoot.
Õpetaja: Tema juba. Teab, kuidas Windowsissa.
Õpetaja: Kun se on Jaova virtuaalimaisi. Missä on Linuxis? Söötä tai sisäiset jaava koot. Joita tea, kuidas Linuxis Mistä puhtamaan. Mäkikö saman moodi, kun me Muutamme sieltä, Flows, että meillä on arendaja kirjoittaa kooti.
Õpetaja: Human Reedable Code siis tulla. Kompilator on nykänavent
Õpetaja: eheätämällä Jehovan virtuaalimaisin. No, tämä on lapsi. Swindows Is Ace Keskonnaksi konnaksi käskyläksi.
Õpetaja: Mitenkä pitäisi toimimaan lopuksi siellä täysin Taustalaprosessori, Siis mitä näitten? Hello Worldissa.
Õpetaja: Nyt kun me räägimme Frontendistä, Siis Frontend ei ole jaavan kompileerittava. Me voimme lähtökoot ja kompileirimme.
Õpetaja: Javascript on interpreteerit.
Õpetaja: Siellä vahea on se, että siellä tuli möttäjällisät No päivän Lopuksi Samoin kuitenkin protsessoriini ilman mitään toimettomia tekemään
Õpetaja: Jaavas kritik. Käskutexnlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign Missä Konkreettisessa. Systeemissä Pääsisivät Toimimaan Windows Ja Macoin. Ja Siellä On Vähän
Õpetaja: Miksi Hot, reinout kod siis kiire pelkentättäkseen. Se käskutex
Õpetaja: hotelli oskabset. Suht Viitsin tehdä sitä. Kiireet. Vaativat, että minä muuten vähän tähän ärää. Vaata missään, Taustalla muuttamaan jalakaan ei ole loogiikkaa ja funktsionaalisuus ja
Õpetaja: taas käivittää. Tai on, kun te päätte Frontend käimmässä näitten teiltä teki nykyinen link Local Host kahdeksankymmentäkahdeksan. X.
Õpetaja: Maili sisu.
Õpetaja: Nyt? Mitä te näite? Meillä dokumentti?
Õpetaja: Se on siis kirja. Viisi, Millest arvuttiin, Kuinka tavainimene saavat molemmat tekeli kun Taroi se poti osaaminen rohkem kuin haetaan mielestä vaan osa. Missä on nähtävä hetkeillä on ainut yksi ridateksti.
Õpetaja: Missä on siellä potin? Seessä? Sitä Tyleään otan nissan välille kommenteeritut. Vai ovatkin kommentaarit tu tuo laissa. Mitä tehdään, kun minä otan? Sitten teistä. Ara sellä otan sitten
Õpetaja: ja siis, Tämä on osa sellaisesta koodista. Kun minä nyt vaataksin Nyt
Õpetaja: siellä Front Enty Scrollin ylässä ja tein siellä linkin lahteen. Siis siinä itse terämile, että näitä kommentaareita se ei säily. Sitä on näin kommentaari. Se on ainukene osa. Päris gotis.
Õpetaja: Missä Mätää on se että on hot realalt On se, että kun minä koodistelen. Aaaaa
Õpetaja: siis. Siihen tulee kaapua. Ahaa, minä pitänyt serverin käyttämään Se on hotriloita. On kenellekin kysymys ja hotriloita mitään.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa mitä me emme tekemään? Okamme on se, että me tahoamme ja kenasti toimia tätä.
Õpetaja: Me emme saa kaikkeen asti toimeen tätä, Master Harus
Õpetaja: Nyt olisi sellainen hetki, kun me teemme nimetä, että me teemme. Mikä on yksi isäntä haru? Mätätte siellä kitimettä. Eli me saamme sanoisprojektist sekamatta. Mutta räksenin minä ajan Jarostafin. Tämä kustutetaan ja tämä a tähtää pannaan. Minä tai B tähtapäin. Ja, No, missä tulee
Õpetaja: Siis Onkin se, että ensimmäisenä savuna.
Õpetaja: Missä Pruun täpselt tee? Panen Kitten comit, bla, bla, bla. Panen siellä sinne Erä te voitte tehdä. Update.
Õpetaja: Tulette siihen ja Aiotte Fedge
Õpetaja: vapautusta. Minulla ei ole vielä pushenut. Sorry,
Õpetaja: Minäkin kun mittisin tai olemaan vielä välillä punainen joon
Õpetaja: miskin lähipä pilveä ennen kuin minä itse. No, mitä Bussin on väittänyt? Kaksi kortaa. Se juon vain, että kun se tulee olemaan, ette vaatlik.
Õpetaja: Nyt te saatte tehdä Fetcheaa täällä näyttämään, että olet vähän yhä komiitikalla, että maassa
Õpetaja: siis tätä update.
Õpetaja: Se tuli. Minkä takaisin? Tely? Ch Sään erinevat. Haudut mistä olen olemassa että Siitä näppitään ja välitä. Eikä sitä valikkoja, Mistä saa vaikka ne valikot. Missä on siinä ylävällä kehtivät sellainen harukohta kuin sitä hetkellä aletaan
Õpetaja: Update on yksi ja se sama asia.
Õpetaja: Master Haru. Update niin,
Õpetaja: kun te Nyt olette siellä. Erä Teine Nyt on siis seisammin kuin teemme. Kun lähevät lahkuun. Minä teen nyt. Sanotaan kaasaan saman moodi. Tulkaa Siellä Horun mainonsa päälle ja valitsee New Branch.
Õpetaja: Mitä se nyt tee On se että on. Me teemme nyt oman harun. Kun me saamme toimia tätä minä panen sijaa opettaa ja
Õpetaja: piisa vesnimässä kuitenkin. Jopa, että panna sen Ja viid. Yksi versio on yksi.
Õpetaja: Kun niin tähtisiä ei ole. Vaikka siis. Kun me hakkamme parissa tekemään, siis on se, että te teette Minkä
Õpetaja: te jätä minusta mahaa? Minkä asian? Katkeen, Minkä Ei siellä punaiseksi. Me Emme hakkaa uurimaan. Miksi kenelläkin on? Mitä punainen kuskillä kuulon puutuve Ja Jumala tea, missä se ei anna meille minkälaista väestöstä
Õpetaja: Me Pidämme Glasshirroom sopimaan niin teemassa. Meillä on paljon kattavaa, jotta me lähdemme koko ketään
Õpetaja: järki tuellaan Alatti on se, että tämä minun harustani ja huueen haru ja panette siinä viid kaksi.
Õpetaja: No Missä valesti on, koska te Saatte sitä parasta tehdä koko ajan löytää uuden harun
Õpetaja: no. Miten, ja niin edes te saatte tullilla kiireet minulle järki. On täht täht sama. Minä olen. Miksi me kokku lepimme selväksi. On siis se, että kun järki tullilla, rain T yksi comit siis minua. Se, että pushin
Õpetaja: metsälää Pillää aikakohdaksi. Te Jätitte siis sentään Fetchi New Branche
Õpetaja: Tuen sitä omaa nimeään. Ei, Kaksi missään kanssa on, Se että saat äänestä. Kiire tulla minulle järkeen.
Õpetaja: Se ei ole väärtus, että kuskil on minkäkin asian katkein opettaja te viitte Pragulta, kun siellä ei pidä yksityistä. Puhua.
Õpetaja: Ten haru, kun oli nykyään Tick Box. Checkout. Tuo tepsis. Kaksi toiminut koeraika erään olemaan. Entä nimi? On Niin
Õpetaja: minä pankit muut asiat kiinni. Niin sitten Vaatatessa näkemään oman lokaaliaan masterittejä Sentä nimeä samaa
Õpetaja: jotka sitten, ovat repoikustat olemassa mitä opettajan päältä Push
Õpetaja: siis Tulemaan? Nykäinen asia kuin origin ja Teidän nimenne tyttö muuttukikaan. Pilvenhat Remote. Origin Track Branche Moni
Õpetaja: bussitaan alas. Siis se pitäisi pohjimmat pilvään. Se On viippi natukene aikaa ottaa
Õpetaja: no Minultakin on varaa. Siis kun teillä ei ole. Kun minä oleksi projektipannut kuin Collaborator, siis te ei ole saanut sitä liikutusta.
Õpetaja: Teillä on oma Kittaapi kontoo projekti. Mitä kuskil downloaditaan ja vaadataan. Ja
Õpetaja: siis työt siellä aina tehdä C kellä jolla on lupa
Õpetaja: kumminkin voiras, ihminen ei saa Tulla kootipääs ja muuttamaan,
Õpetaja: mitä enemmän luvataan. No, kun minä olen esimerkiksi tyttöjen Fetch, siis suuren työnäosus. Remote alla pitäisi tulemaan Wale
Õpetaja: Pushileinon ärä
Õpetaja: Nyt se ei ole kuitenkin tähtis, ettei se pilves on. Ja minä ytan teille, että. Missä minä en nyt järkminen sana. Hakkamme tekemään. Me Hakkamme vaatimaan. Ei teknologiaa, että hotell Ccs Javascript. Steppa I, Steppa
Õpetaja: se. Mistä me nyt teemme? Tässä hetkessä kun ei ole teattu hetkeen ja on lykikastikauppa.
Õpetaja: Se ei ole enää kuin meidän päris projektina. Me hakkamme tekemään. Mitä minä illan Näyttäisin teillä? Mitä Me hakkamme tekemään?
Õpetaja: Se on alle se, että me tuntemaan. Missä on nyt se meidän mängumaa. Missä me saamme koskuttaa omaa frontendi?
Õpetaja: Siinä on niin prykikäistä. Ei pidä tinkimättä kaasa tekemään vaikka litsataan ja järki ei ole kirjoittaa sinne. Minkälaisia kommentaareja? Että litsat meen tämä,
Õpetaja: että jos
Õpetaja: arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies eivät ole otsa vaja.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Ja siis läksit sinna. Stop, Ylisovi.
Õpetaja: Se Ei ole ylitse. Tähtis
Õpetaja: ei jää millestekin mahaa ja pratetaan niin vaatimassa kohtaa. Ja niin kuin niin kuin jäävärdöstä.
Õpetaja: Niin, milläs nyt Kun Taan rääkida on? Siis Alustamme siis sellaista hotellistä.
Õpetaja: Missä asian Html Minulla onkaan. Monet vanhat materiaalit. Missä natukene yhteisträgi ovat?
Õpetaja: Vaatimaan ja lisänneet läpi. Minun arvioitten
Õpetaja: arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: Minä En mäleta Olette kuullut. Nyt sahat.
Õpetaja: Meillä on siis pikataan Hypertext. Marc up. Language
Õpetaja: Tekstin merkitys keli. No, näen tämän pari Selvää.
Õpetaja: Milläkö on tekemistä. On siis sellisen dokumentin? Mitä Brause roskap, Siis visualiseerija.
Õpetaja: Se sama veibil kino kavat. Missä on taustalla Page Source on Hotmail Document.
Õpetaja: Se on tekstifine.
Õpetaja: Ei kai ole kuitenkin Mainita ei ole võimalik. Auto on maagilisia, että saatte kellekin Browserissa. Julkiset visuaaliset interaktiiviset pilttiin,
Õpetaja: kun raua tasan teillä lähemmässä nuillitönöhet mistä käsutiedotusprinsiipissä, on että tekemistä ovat nämä tekstidokumentin.
Õpetaja: Sitten mitäkin. Siinä on Kirjaus Kino kauan nätalaiksi.
Õpetaja: Mailis Controller F.
Õpetaja: Minä en tiedä, kun tässä kokku pannakse jotain Mitäkin litsa Filmit Kiinokaavaa.
Õpetaja: Näitä taiteilijatkin ovat. Kavassa on ylitseä.
Õpetaja: Se on kinokava.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa eik. Siis Meillä nykyään nämä dokumentit, mitä ihminen ja lukevat on meillä dokumenttinsä.
Õpetaja: Siis on meille heidosa ja Botiosa
Õpetaja: Nyt Heido. Osa on siukene. Osa mistä suuresti ei ole aikaa nähtävää. Sinne saa Vicasugust Staffi Vann. Sinä saa panna linkeja sinänsä. Pannaan linkkästiili täällä sinänsä, vikasukuisia asioita ja ainukene nähtävä osa. Missä tämä sitten on?
Õpetaja: Ylitse on taiteilla Mutta kun me vaatimme, sitä, että meillä on siis vita up.
Õpetaja: Kun me vaatimme omaa lokaalista serveritsisi. Niin Tabi Bell on Wit up One
Õpetaja: Head osas. Aha, bitvateen. Siinä on nykänen systeemi, että Itä. Asia on siinä arvuttijaista aruskoopista kulatuses.
Õpetaja: Vaikka se Taggiks koeräikin, minä olen kautta. Kuusikymmentäkahdeksantoista on alkus.
Õpetaja: Osa on selvä. On head osa. Siinä on eräti. Taitalla alkaa taitaa löpää ja päris taitaa. Aa, siis on loomulikult siellä,
Õpetaja: arvoisa Se heito osa on suuresti nähtämätön osa.
Õpetaja: Missä on nähtävä osa? On poti osa,
Õpetaja: Kun me sitten vaatimme meidän potilkapsit
Õpetaja: kun ei tule sieltä Reanumbrita Juuri sinne kahdesta puolesta. Minä väitän. Nimeni siellä päälle. Tömbab siellä koko
Õpetaja: Real Sataseitsemän. Pikemmin satakuusitoista on tema.
Õpetaja: Lähme Realle Satakuusitoista.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Se on se että kaikki, Missä on sen potin on siis se nähtävä osa lehekülöstöä.
Õpetaja: Body Says on kiri, Terämaailma ja reelikölt. Me ei Näytä tässä terä. Maailma Duplicatedrinitiallangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign
Õpetaja: Mantera Mantera Mantera. Samamoodi kyllöinyt niimoodi että naton reaal.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa oikein Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: No Okei rohkem saattamisen dokumentinkin. Kun vaatakset ylä takaa meille
Õpetaja: se siis on niin kuin kukku. Lepiteknologia ja standard
Õpetaja: tehdä suurkoncertiuman, kes lepit kokku. Jaa, nyt teemme niistä asiaa, Se on standard, Arvoisa niin
Õpetaja: kaikkein huomat. Browserit laittavat sitä kenasti.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme Väsin
Õpetaja: siis järvinen. Asia on missä asiassa ja vaskirtet tervikuna.
Õpetaja: Kolme Põhiteknologiat mitä katsottiin veibilehtien tai luomiseksi ja kuvaamiseksi. Ja iga. Yksi mänkin veibilekujen tämmöisellä. Me olemme koskaan
Õpetaja: hotellin Peaminen. Mötä on se, että annan meille veibilehdestruktuurin ja sisu.
Õpetaja: Me räägimme nyt sellisen viisilvaan, että meillä on ritman
Õpetaja: tekstiverotetaan. Meillä on tekst Kus on paragraf.
Õpetaja: Meillä on pealkiri.
Õpetaja: Suuremmalla meillä on.
Õpetaja: Meillä on link.
Õpetaja: Meillä On checkbox. Checkboxat. Nuput
Õpetaja: Asiat ovat sisu ja struktur. Jahva Script. No, saa veits Fookus Pookus. Tehdään esimerkiksi Cscsekään ei ole viimailikka ja teki juuri tämä
Õpetaja: rituja, vaan se hotell on meidän ainukene mängumaa. Milläkö me saamme lähelle yöllä, että siinä onkin sukkaisiin.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies menee. Checkbox. Mitä
Õpetaja: nyt, Css? Tämä on siis stiili ja veebilehdin vaikutus Ajax.
Õpetaja: Kun me räägimme, että minulla on siellä Kaksi pilti on kysymys, vaan yksi sote. Isä ei pea alle.
Õpetaja: Ei niin, paljon eemalää. Se kõik on Csss.
Õpetaja: Lisätään funktionalskejärjestelmääräjähtävissä.
Õpetaja: Hotell on struktuur Ja sisu ja Javascripton funktionalsus ja action sanapäivä.
Õpetaja: Okei, no, siinä on näitä. Taustalla ovat siis maissa. Mistä eivät säilää asiaa Selliseksi
Õpetaja: Siinä on kaintana. Kun näitä haata meille ilmaa. Seesit niin paljon kuin moskasin. Maahan nutitään, kun sisu on aika palainen kuin minkit stiiliit,
Õpetaja: kun kuitenkin klikitsisi. Mitäkin
Õpetaja: siis Ervin esimerkiksi lähti poikkimaan, että kun tässä Htmell sitten natukene, jopa rääkisin.
Õpetaja: Yksi ja ainutkos. Me kasutamme märgändit. Märgendit alkavat ja löpäävät, Tämäkin
Õpetaja: on siis veibileht ja sisu määräämiseksi. Monet meistä vajaavat. Oliko se löptäheistä kuin teiset Mitä
Õpetaja: pohjois on Sellainen, että Monet märgentit vaativat täpsustamista? Milloin en de muju Oliko vielä, samassa kuin teissä tai niissä seisovat?
Õpetaja: No, vipsin. Tuo siis textilik.
Õpetaja: Se onkin tämä tekstileikiparagraf.
Õpetaja: Nyt kun luen, että Raamatut voitaisiin liikut vaan yksi teinen löykös saattaa aruna aikoja Väkiset vahepausitan.
Õpetaja: Tämä siis koko se teksti olemaan kahden sellisena alkaa
Õpetaja: Textil Politics Tekeminen Strong ja Strong. Meitä on kahet hääkin.
Õpetaja: Selliset elementit. Niitä kutsuttaisiin elementteiksi. Menyy elementit? Osat elementit. Ehkä osa Venäjät.
Õpetaja: Sanoikoil osat? Elementit ovat Siis kahe Gigan ja osat on buildil.
Õpetaja: Siis on alternative. Siinä on Lhv kaart. Miten
Õpetaja: T? Yksi reavan vahetus, mutta ei ole vain jo Alkosta lepoa tai te lehdelle. Realvahetus.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa, mitä me emme nyt? Hakkamme tekemään kohtaa. Viipkaa tekemään yhdeksänkymmentä stiilis. Veivilehtä Pangala.
Õpetaja: Stilis lehdet olivat aika Brutaaliset kainana kuuluu yhä värvilisät muusikataustalla käymään. Värvit olivat populaarne.
Õpetaja: Ja miksei me teemme kyllä pankan lehekylle, kun klientti näihin saadaan mitäkin, tavallista tekemään
Õpetaja: on ainut tutvusta näitä elementtejä. Taikka. Mitä meiltä jättää? Kutas ne kirjoitetakseen. Se saa Roman
Õpetaja: että meille pitäisi kirjoittaa. Teat Minä kumotaan pilttiin siis Joka vimmallisuus on olemassa,
Õpetaja: On olemassa Kumotaan kasti, kun kirjoitetaan teksti. Se on võimalus kumotaan kasti, kun se on Password tai näy, mitä kirjoittajat Siis on olemassa kumotaan. Esimerkiksi kalenterivalikot. Otamme kuukauden välillä. Siis joka asia on olemassa.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies, Minä tean. Minä
Õpetaja: Meidän pankkamme. On vähän suurempi Ja erittäin jäkää pankki olevan Sitä saa tehdä.
Õpetaja: Celeax on H. Yksi.
Õpetaja: Kun pannaan H. Yksi ja nyt vajutetaan Täp siis teeb sellist kahden Kahdensa tagin.
Õpetaja: Vai? Niin, kun minä olen kirjoittanut joilla on Html Is olemassa.
Õpetaja: Haa yksi ja tulen sitten nolla. Nimet jo alla.
Õpetaja: Yksi yksi Ja nollakaan siis te vainotte. Alkoti saisi. Missä on olemassa
Õpetaja: kuivan taakseni, että on yhä tääkin linjassa me. Pannaan gold Griepson Jota, lopettaa siellä Erä ja ne elementit. Missä on yhä tää alternatiiva? On se että, minä valitan siitä tääpi ei
Õpetaja: enter. Ei Okei, cetatekstissä Nimeä nyt kun Sieman kirjoitetaan meidän.
Õpetaja: Pannaan esimerkiksi, kun nyt vaatette sitä. Lehekylkää siis. Meidän vankien mukaan. Nähtävä tämä ei myöskään.
Õpetaja: Se on selvää, että kun minulla on yksi programlahti. Sitten minus Tulen välin,
Õpetaja: kun minä nyt tulen. Valin lihtsalt siellä.
Õpetaja: Windowsissa. Valmis, Alttibeal Yksi avo. Minä teisellä kraanilla, kun se Ei ole Share. Saat valita Miss File.
Õpetaja: Ne saat valita. Se on. Kuka nyt teiselle kraanille? Jos kyllä ollaan?
Õpetaja: Vaikka se nyt on se Konksa, että kun minä olen katsonut ja olen Slack katsojonut, Kun minä nyt teen asti kiireellisesti tätä vaikkea.
Õpetaja: Siis Tämä paliviisat, Arvoisa puhemies, Miksi On se head. Teada On se, mitä me tahamme. Tehdä.
Õpetaja: Ja nyt täällä saamme kiireet vaadata.
Õpetaja: On luomulikku. Pannaanatka yhdellä ekraanilla, kun te voitte Tämän Windows nuppu päällä.
Õpetaja: Nuolake ne paremmalle lahti ja valittaa minkälaisia vasakkuolää siis saa niin
Õpetaja: pystynyt klikkimään siihen. Ikävaatte että aina kun aktiveeriksi
Õpetaja: minun lentälleni. Vaikka se ei meeldi minulle meeldi pikemmin nimetä, että minä litsa hyppänen tai kysymys ja signaali ole.
Õpetaja: Ja siis teemme
Õpetaja: ja onkin kun me nyt siellä otetaan. Erittäin jätä pankkaa, kun te laitatte listat haapl siis telliksi. Yritän mainitakaa, mitä saisin taas tehdä, näyttää? Että Niitä on kokku. Tasä meni kuusi.
Õpetaja: No panemin johaan Eli ja kirjoittanut sijaa. Erittäin
Õpetaja: siis on erinomainen.
Õpetaja: Kun minä pannaan H seitsemään, siis se on jopa Jama H. Kahdeksan
Õpetaja: näitten Juoneetakin olla tekstiltä. Tai josko milläkin muukselta tehdä arvoisa järvinen on paragraf siis minkään tekstiläyksi.
Õpetaja: Paragraf. Jopa oli oli siis P
Õpetaja: Paragrafaan, että kirjoitamme siia. No, satamme kopin
Õpetaja: Ahaa, missä on se?
Õpetaja: Ei, se on vaenlainen.
Õpetaja: Se on arendaja. Vaenlalainen.
Õpetaja: Mistä on areenaa? Lailla
Õpetaja: Paillesän
Õpetaja: pointti on se, että sinä kirjoittajat kootia ja teet niitäkin uskokaan. Jo mittäisi, kun te tunnette että suunnittyneet haaraamaan? Hiilen sillä hetkellä ei tarvitse. Riittääkö tekemään sellaisissa? Rannassa
Õpetaja: on minusta kirjoittaa tämä kooti nimeä, että kun te olette kunagi märkkäinen, että kun te vaatate Keyboardin uppe F Ja jo et missään tätä. Puhun tähän.
Õpetaja: Siellä on väikeänä. En ole minkä sanaa tunneksit, kun sanotaan jopa käpäjun paikka pannonut isäkin kuitenkin oja Aina päriseikästä ja stiilmi. Mitä Viljeletään ja
Õpetaja: ei vattaklaature.
Õpetaja: Kuulkaa jokseen mitäkin. Tekin, että se onkaan? Kun taisi millä puolella pyyältä oli vain puoleen Thatchipitti ajastolla
Õpetaja: on niin topealta tarjottu sieltä kirjoittamaan sen on minunkin viitsi. Sinne myös Teiltä vist arvata
Õpetaja: Kaksi tuntia. Minä rohkeammin viitsi vaan kahdeksannut. Olisiko sanoa jopa kahden tunnin, kun niimoodi harjoittaessaan? Pari seana alkunsa Kättä.
Õpetaja: Kointi, väännöt. Missä nimi oli? Ja It s Fine
Õpetaja: Prinsipistä on, on Aika, kun ei pimeä kirjaa valita. Siis minkin kuju. Se on aika okei, kun ei tähtilaan veits. Puitokaa Backspace
Õpetaja: siellä Venäjän kanssa.
Õpetaja: Natukene vailla, Meillä, jotka kohaatti tämän parin säpärän, että on hetket ajat. Kun me emme sovi Skiporteria toimia tätä rinkin soprata vaan toimia tätä. No, kuin minun sanan Hiina ja sieltä tehdään.
Õpetaja: Kun me kirjoitamme nämä koot, siis me tekeille, kun yrittäisimme tehdä niimoita ja että me emme kasuta sitä, Mentä vain täärmisel juhul
Õpetaja: nyt kiipoilta. Vielä. Joku saa meidät juurikaan. Ja kuitenkin on tava kiipo, jota on alati parempi kuin laptopi. Keeport. Nupuut ovat märksäämmät, mutta on mukava vajuttaa tai tunne, että se on. Parempi Plus ei ole minkään Fn jamaa.
Õpetaja: Keyboardilla on suruttu Paljon nuput tai Nupu alla functionitoimen alla. Teat ovat väet. Minä itse lauantaakaan keyboardille. Pannaan siis ehkä saadaan,
Õpetaja: kun se saa tämmöinen läpäkkä kiinnipannaan ja vaatad suuret Monitorit silme ja sitten oman koon tiedotetaan.
Õpetaja: No siis on. Läpakkasin kuitenkin. Minä
Õpetaja: kun kohan. Yritän niin kuin läpakkasi niin kaukalle ja kun saa Tämä keyboardit. Hir siitä ei katsota.
Õpetaja: Ja arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Ei arentaa. Ei tee köyhää. Kuvaa, Savikka, Suurkuvaa.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: On kaksi valikoota? Siellä on Kaksi monitorilla. Siellä on yksi suur arentaa, että suomen kooti kirjoitetaan.
Õpetaja: Ei saakaan. Ammoja on vähän Siellä on koko ajan vaja. Laatat, että se Ei ole jopa vika tämän vettämiseksi.
Õpetaja: Kun juuri se, että kun sitä saattaa hakata kootin ekraanilla.
Õpetaja: Minussa on nimet ja kirjoittaa jopa harjoon, kun Siinä on esimerkiksi Forward Slash. No, kuidas saa väljäkommenteeritaan? Vaikkimisia on Control ja Forward Slash
Õpetaja: Kommenteerin näitä inteeli seis.
Õpetaja: No, kun teillä on nyt Frontend is teillä. Onlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign
Õpetaja: Kenellä oli itse Tallerika Tehty minä Olen tehnyt Control Shift ja Seitsemän Enamusihmistä Joilla on Seitsemän välsää
Õpetaja: Leppä kanssa. Ja Kall Gribson. Niin,
Õpetaja: Control. Shift Seitsemän toimimaan. Se oli minun sellin Stallers. Se on delegation. Extra seatistos.
Õpetaja: Tulemme takaisin sille paragrafiin, jota minun minä Jollakin koken.
Õpetaja: Otan sitten Minkin tekstin, jos näitan ga ett paragraf. Mutta nyt on se, että minä teen sieltä mitu korda sin nimetä. Paragraf,
Õpetaja: Kun Minulla on kaksisataa, me voimme tublit Tsein vaatamaan. Siis on kaksi leikkaa saattomaan.
Õpetaja: Niin, ajetaan siis siellä vähän eteenpäin, että on yksi leikka. Siinä meni yhdessä Stilis Bank järvinen spänn.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: Ulottu. Sen myötä on se, että oletamme, että meillä Onkin Cmi yhdeksänkymmentä stiilis Bank ja Taakse näiteeksi tehdään yhdeksänkymmentätuhatta. Stiilistä. Tehdään lisät punaisiksi.
Õpetaja: Minä panen natukene sinne tekstiä vielä vaan paremmin. Kun sieltä arusaata, että Oletteko me.
Õpetaja: Minulla on Semminkin tekstiä. Minä tahan just sille. Osataan siinä punaiseksi.
Õpetaja: Sieltä Suf Kiss Panny Abil tehdä
Õpetaja: Nimet eivät panke se alku siia, yhdeksää kymmenettä ja Voi olla stiilis järki.
Õpetaja: Oliko se, että mihin olemaan?
Õpetaja: Ja Monelle on kerraltinut Niin kun vaataatte eikä praakutti saa mitään autoa, että juhtisi
Õpetaja: me Emme ole stiiliä annoneet tekstillä kuin on se yläinen tekstiä.
Õpetaja: Niin, nyt on järvinen Asia, millä tahan rääkida, on Attribuut eh omatus.
Õpetaja: Elementti täällä Ja omaellut kirjoittamaan esimiestissä tää kisissään elementsissä onkin. Yksi tää
Õpetaja: Kuin On elementti siis me. Kirjoitamme sisään me kasutamme. Viikot Minä Olen Kirjoittanut Style Tabi.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, Nyt on se kaisivää tai ärkän. Kirjyttäkää asiaa kuin tämä paku Meitä tulee Style tapsolle.
Õpetaja: Nyt pannaan Color, Jälle tämä.
Õpetaja: Minäkin te Tietenkin kuulleni. Kaa, Caps Lock Itlangenglish.
Õpetaja: Siinä on nyt edes piti kun vielä erään muuta. Toimisiko Rexelta aikaa? Monet ihmiset ovat valikudenterika minua on Aika lähetellä nupp vasakkolla. Ja täällä
Õpetaja: entrimes.
Õpetaja: Olen minkin värvi. Siinä on. Minkälaiset color? Coatit Minkä listat kirjoitetaan? Reet.
Õpetaja: Nyt on Niimoodi paragrafi Seison. Siinä on meijää
Õpetaja: yhdeksänkymmentä Stilis Banken. Ja kun tullaan vaatamaan, sieltä, siis saattaisi painimään, että starrohton ulatuisi
Õpetaja: This is so nins vanasti, niin oli
Õpetaja: Stiil stiilimme. Milläkö me teemme stiili?
Õpetaja: No, millä me juomekaan luotamme?
Õpetaja: Siinä ei ole vain mitään mieltä jättävää, että oi, kun tässä täpset käivata Ja missä kirjoittamaan päässä puolella on võimalik rohkem
Õpetaja: sen jaoksi että, sinä saat isäntä lainkaan ja avas
Õpetaja: sinä. Saat Lihtsalt jättää täällä märkman mitä, Tehdään Minulla onkin. Mitä minä sen läpi käymme?
Õpetaja: Järvinen break.
Õpetaja: Mitä Break on? Tyhji Rida meidän banksemme Yksittäisen Vrl.
Õpetaja: Panen Br ja panen täp Ja panen Control D Duplicated.
Õpetaja: Siis te näette tulevat. Nyt Se tyhjät rajat,
Õpetaja: kun minä teensälää mitä yhäkin elementin sees, olen kyllä poti sees. Aika. Minä olen yhäkään alamme. Elementin sees. Kun minä teen siene
Õpetaja: miljoon tykki ka teha. Aga tämäkin seisonemaan. Se ole viisakas,
Õpetaja: siis on igasugiset Voimaudet kaa. Ja
Õpetaja: kun me taamme siis spreikkaan nimeteen. No siinä nyt nimetä, että selkä ei läässä niissä pannakse kaksi breikkiä näitä.
Õpetaja: Siinä on Meidän pankkainen. Ja minkä järvinen asia? Missä me teemme? Ei, tuleeko Äänselka
Õpetaja: minä Ymmärtänyt sitä että, me tänä päivänä saamme sen ei kasvattaa minä. Kysyn, miksi.
Õpetaja: Miksi me Ceta elementti kiskillä.
Õpetaja: Css on stiiliä paikoitus. No, kun sinä sovit yksityistä sieltä vähän töitä. Siis sinä teet sieltä Cscsekään mitään. Se ei lisää isäkapta. Ja
Õpetaja: tähän
Õpetaja: arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Ja kun se kirjoitetaan, joku Pr ja väittää, että nyt tämä
Õpetaja: Onko enemmän sinun toimissani Arvoisa puhemies,
Õpetaja: arvoisa herra puhemiesneuvottelua niinkin symbolista. Kaikki laittaa, että ennen toimintaan.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies
Õpetaja: siinä että näyttää.
Õpetaja: Tämä ei ole enää demaris.
Õpetaja: Kaikki vaativat syytäkseen. Nämä.
Õpetaja: Tämä on siiamaani ja arvoltaessa kirjoittaakseni koko ajan yhtään Tekstin tavoittelun hylkäs. Tässä vähän
Õpetaja: kopin, Jos eläin vaan viedään vaan siellä iso Myynti vaan.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies, täällä onkin se, että kuskit näitä asioita.
Õpetaja: Siis syn taakse, että ylä voi olla nykyään nämä Error. Minun monen kerran siellä takaisin.
Õpetaja: Kun Kuntaxe Stand Up Mercoa.
Õpetaja: Kovinkin vähän symbolinen Tulijat ovat kaikkein
Õpetaja: barusanota kaavaa. Että Kus, vika on siellä Erroriveellä.
Õpetaja: Punainen, jonka
Õpetaja: jos oskat sitä asiaa, niin kuin aloitti, vaikka kuin reksalt kuvata. Mistä arvovalta on Kaikkialla ei ole mitään, ja että se Natukene.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa nyt järkeinen esimerkki. Otamme vaatia, että tämä on list meidän pankakonttorit. Panemme minkäkin? Haaa viisi kirjoittamaan meidän pangaa
Õpetaja: konttorit
Õpetaja: Nyt annetaan listiin Nyt listinkaan on että kun me tahoamme Bullet pointti tänä nykyistä elementtiä Ul.
Õpetaja: Ja kun me tahamme järjestää Numbritannia, kolme siis on ol en Mälättekö meiltä jättää näitä, kun on aika vajaa? Kyllä etsitään.
Õpetaja: Me teemme sen. Alku siis Bullet Pointita aikaa, että
Õpetaja: näitä siinä pakkuvat. Tai Sanoitte, että vaikka all on minkisukykyinen temppel
Õpetaja: ja meillä on Plussoin juures minunkin muu asia, joka ruttua enemmän H. Viitsi
Õpetaja: nykyistä elementtiä. Ysikelementti Kun te Näette nykyistä templit ja blusseet niin kuin Siinä on. Siis kihiilinä elementtejä.
Õpetaja: Yksi rita. Ajaa. Minkä asian vahel? Jos me olemme tehneet kun nyt, Tulee se taajan valita, Siis jatkaisin ometti mässä. Tämä
Õpetaja: siis näitä. Mistä teki niimoodi. Bullet Point, Arvoisa
Õpetaja: Ja nyt tema on seskoopi. Vahel kun Minä luetan siellä vain.
Õpetaja: Demon Ses on eraldi Element list ja list lista item. Eli arvoisa herra puhemies, Arvoisa herra puhemies,
Õpetaja: nyt kun minä taakse tarttua, että otavalta saaks praegult tehdä teiltä.
Õpetaja: Controll D. Niin, nyt on nimet ja nyt olisi vaja. Se taillinasi. Että Tartutokaa ne.
Õpetaja: Nyt On se, että nyt etäisi tehdään On yksi valinta. Läks nimittäin.
Õpetaja: Minä En rääkisinä, että selekteeritaan. Tekstiä, kun minä olen tuskin tällä Select Word
Õpetaja: Kun voittaa, myöhäkoiran veil päällä pakkokin. Mis siis juhtui?
Õpetaja: Eikö ole läheb lajemmaksi?
Õpetaja: Takuripinitiallangenglish tihtipeale. Shiftan shiften samma nuppuen.
Õpetaja: Se mitä kättä harjo Tätä Minä tiedän, mitä tässä
Õpetaja: minä edun, Sees. Kun me taas sitä, minä tulenkin sen. Control D. Istun siinä kenasti vaell, Controll. Kaksi V. Ja Nyt jopa kirjoittain. Missä tarttuu
Õpetaja: Jidet saa tehdä? Se olisi normaalia viljandiga. Kontroll, v Miljardi.
Õpetaja: Okei, luotanko Jos minun koiraani on kuiski lahti, Kaa Knowledge, Pacema Teisa Spacealla. Vai te
Õpetaja: Intelligence Orgardedrinitiallangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeignlangforeign
Õpetaja: minä olen tehnyt kaikki tästä enää Koskatan ja Leha Intelligence Shorcut
Õpetaja: siinä on aika Lyhkäiset videot No, vaikka me Control Select Wordsori hetkeä kohas mitmekordselle vajutaselle Paula,
Õpetaja: maailman kaikkein lyhin video. Wow, yhdeksänsataaneljäkymmentäyhdeksän puhemies.
Õpetaja: Minä olen tehnyt sillä erää että Saisi toimia.
Õpetaja: Mitä se tee, bla bla, bla, bla, bla. Teillä on olemassa kenasti.
Õpetaja: Voin visata Bragutzia Linki
Õpetaja: tässä lisää ylässä. Teillä on konferenssilla likipääs olemassa haluan. Vaatakaa, kun minä olen samalla Mootin, Kun minä olen kunagi ajin tellitsitaksin Kasutama ja minä sain aru. Tässä käpat kyllä avaattaa
Õpetaja: Leitin sieltä. Minkälaisen laiv? Presentatsioonin. Kun sekin ihminen kun täällä on plaanista, mitä kaikkea tehdä. Kuidas
Õpetaja: te kulutatte tämän. Aika. Te viittaatte siellä takaisin.
Õpetaja: Te saatte grikselle takaisin Tuhannen kortset lopussa.
Õpetaja: Samoin Voivatko jopa näitä asiat läpi ja veits Meiltä alkuisessa on jylää Paljon asioita, Mitä meillä edes hoitaa. Uskokaa Asiaa lopuksi. Käppaa niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kun sinä hakkaat, mitäkin tekemään ja tunnet, että sinulla on vaja, mitäkin tehdään Ja sanotaan, että käppä hirälle mennä siis möttää koiraan teoreettilista tuo voimaan elikkä käsitsi ja kanssa sovitsit sitä tehdä Käsitsi
Õpetaja: hiirenhaarat Ainut minne on itset yllässä kuin Tässä
Õpetaja: pointti On siis se, että siis, kosutat ceta? Variantteja Lähdet vaativat, kun tässä käsitsi tehdään teet käsitsi
Õpetaja: Se johtui varoittaa. Noin. Kolme, neljä kortaa.
Õpetaja: Keyboard Ei voitaisiin vaikka se jää meiltä.
Õpetaja: Minä Joskaan peas tööltä, Että Mitäs saa tehdä vaan. Kun minä olen keyboardit pealtessa, minua kät eivät saa Lisää tärää. Minun vain visualiseerin enää. Mattelenkin
Õpetaja: nuppea ja sisyttämään tis niin saakka.
Õpetaja: Vot niin, no saimme listin,
Õpetaja: Okei, Ja kun me nyt muutamme Siellä U elisit nimeni. Se voi olla vaatimisen kohta. Pannaan Olx
Õpetaja: Youtube on se, että otan nyt numbri.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Breaking viisakin kaksi.
Õpetaja: Se on nyt ensimmäinen elementtejä. Missä meillä on yhä Tagiga Image, Pmg
Õpetaja: tavallinen nimitys Ja Style on jo tekeli. Kun tuon elementin sees vastat Täällä se on Attribuut
Õpetaja: Source. Se tavallinen image. Source.
Õpetaja: Tämä viikon välin Nyt source on se. Että Hei, Guzman. Sille pilti sisu saan.
Õpetaja: Art on siis Selina esi, jossa on mainittu. Juhul kui sea sisu ei saa renteltä tamminkin pohjoiselle, siis näitettäisiin kaikki se pilti ikooni. Ja minkä
Õpetaja: On Ikään kuin sellaiset vahvap programmit ja Sms Browserist.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa Lhv. Panka, konttorit. Kaart Nämä Tekstit. Missä representeerit
Õpetaja: se nyt on? Niimoodi, että se Ei ole otseselt kohustuslik elämä. Sillä ara. Siis tullaan vaalilla kullaina. Joon
Õpetaja: siinä. On Warning Telein. Se ei ole katkeaa.
Õpetaja: On hienoa tava että Sinulla on ikkana joku Minkin tekst kaa juhul kui pilttoon. Kaikki liiku pimeän soovi kuulemisen
Õpetaja: siellä kohtaa rohkeammalla. Kustutan. Ytkö mitään?
Õpetaja: For image which is mandatory and incredibil used for accessibility screen readers read attribute values out to the users so they know what the image means no Onkin se, että minä en näe. Aivan,
Õpetaja: rääkisin siellä kaupungissa Välillä. Nyt sorssikään nimettiin ja piltivat projektin väliseltä. Tein lahti. Tehkää kakaisaa. Tein lahti Ja oitsin. Sanakaart
Õpetaja: ei lähde nitivun kesään.
Õpetaja: Sitten yllä. Otetaan bildit
Õpetaja: rikensellä.
Õpetaja: Näette, saataisiin, kun minä otan nyt kontrolliksi ja siis siihen pääksi ilmoittaa Se on siellä pilti. Aadressi
Õpetaja: on nyt se, että me ymmärrämme, että kun vaatii lehteä pilttein, missä minulla on Image? Minkit sisu
Õpetaja: testikavaa, että Olen Vain näkijä.
Õpetaja: Niin, kun minä tulen siihen. Muutos teillä tähän.
Õpetaja: Kuten se määrä Kun pienten suuntaan rentäytetään
Õpetaja: sieltä tekstejä plus kun suhteissa renteratetaan Taustalla on Screen Reader Love siellä välillä. Kun Nyt se Lindt Mismoinen kuin Control Web
Õpetaja: pikkioru tule siia. On niin, kun bildtominkin Monster koko lehdä. Ara,
Õpetaja: Minä saan tehdä niimoodi, että minä olen katsottanut vielä yhtä attribuuttia. Tulen siihen, että
Õpetaja: viitsi jo etsitä kuin sen löpöpraakut Siellä tulen siihen, että panen kassoili kaksi. Svee.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa herra puhemies.
Õpetaja: Vaikea pilt, Kun minä panen kaksisata pikslit jukkavit nyt selkäänkaa.
Õpetaja: Tämä ei tasuisi kunnatakin niin tehdä vai Pitäs ja
Õpetaja: viisisataa. Siis Praegu pilttiin. Myytän selkä.
Õpetaja: Alkaa niimoodi, että se source se sisu on defineeritut että se tulee kuskil väljas puolelta. Vaikka tavallinen lähellä menee päriseluun.
Õpetaja: Kun saamme aika mukavaa töitä. Esimerkiksi pilttaa sieltä jaksa tammi suuruisesti erittäin suurta
Õpetaja: laatimaan mahtokokkuus ja alkohaskussa, missä Päinsä taustalla on kuin suuret Annain. Ja mitäkin
Õpetaja: triki että siellä sama builtingvakes tekee eli kun ra sairasta tarvitessaan.
Õpetaja: Se ei viime säästy
Õpetaja: se Voi olla kuin puhtaat vaatamisen kohdat. Panenko sinne Downloads kaustaiselle endale ja panen sinne mihinkään nimeään. Panen näitä,
Õpetaja: kart.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies, Arvoisa herra puhemies Byr Means,
Õpetaja: Minä saan tehdä niimoodi. Tein Browser lahti.
Õpetaja: Kun se kaarti on, Nyt siis teemme nimetat Modified Kart
Õpetaja: tulemaan Control C kopin. Mitkä ovat vanha kuolivärki tai parem Klöpsi. Kopi Control C.
Õpetaja: Tein siellä projektin lahti, että frontendistä tai pannaan siia.
Õpetaja: Control E.
Õpetaja: Kaart.
Õpetaja: Kysyisin, kun sitä On Kitti lisätään. No minä arvoisa
Õpetaja: sinisekseen.
Õpetaja: Siinä on väikin trikkaa. Mitä te kontrolliks? Tavalliset,
Õpetaja: kun kirjoittat. Minkä tekstidokumentteja? Minkä osa tekstistä? Aika? Se On mälus vai Niinkin? Sanan
Õpetaja: minä viitsi ei voi ollenkaan mitään muuta. Täpselt kyllä otavalta kustuttaa Näitä. Minä olen kuskil Siin Real vain Control. X.
Õpetaja: Ainoa asia on se vain, että nyt on tämä mälus.
Õpetaja: Kun minä tahan päriselt setaissa ja kun Mälly saata
Õpetaja: kustutata että siellä asemelle Pannaan. Kun Ajat Controlli X uuesti, siis Minulla ei ole sitä vanaa ässä enää mälusta kun. Minä lopussa panin kontrollen vatten ja tällainen viimeinen asia. Meillä
Õpetaja: nimet eivät saa kustuttaa tämän ruttoa eräässä siniseksi. Ja olette liittovaltiot. Mitä iganes Minä nimetan? Nimeä, että sorsiksi ei lähde mitään. Link, Missä asuvat? Koska siellä väljaspool Voit se sama valmis On minun serveris olemassa
Õpetaja: minua ideani. Kuidas on sortskatalog Wist Ongi Control Tohic
Õpetaja: Mittaka
Õpetaja: tuli Takaisin
Õpetaja: Fronten serveris. Public kuin juurkatalog.
Õpetaja: No, kun minä paneksin siellä, sain seikoon.
Õpetaja: Missä onkö Browseries Meillä on kahte video olla päriselta me enda serveris olemassa
Õpetaja: asuvat kuskil serverissä ja kolmas variantti on se, että annetaan esimerkiksi
Õpetaja: pari saisi alusta. Pilt tulla vannebasista
Õpetaja: ja kun taustalla on joka päiväen. Lopuksi vähän niin olen nimittäin storissa. Pannaan tai
Õpetaja: muu Mistä nämä olosuhteet?
Õpetaja: Okei, se on olemassa sen piltinädän ja tettänä virailemaan
Õpetaja: esimerkiksi tämä on yksi tabeli, jossa on siis Peragonan nimi. Ja se on baarin. Baarin
Õpetaja: Clinton jukkue ja juhainen ja Rain tyyr. Ja
Õpetaja: siis se element Isä on table,
Õpetaja: kun minä jopa kirjoittamassa. Millä minä voiksen Valita ja miksi?
Õpetaja: Table Plus Miksi Table Plus template? Ehkä Mile Pluss Tähän
Õpetaja: täällä on mitme kihiilinä tai sykava.
Õpetaja: Oliko tebellöppä, Vai niin, te Ervixoilla?
Õpetaja: Kuin tekemistä? Tabelina.
Õpetaja: Se siin on yksi rida.
Õpetaja: Missä ollaan teki Diabacki
Õpetaja: Table Tata vaan.
Õpetaja: Eikö siis? Praegu on yksi Rita ja Vr Yksi, Kun meidän on tehdä tabeli, jossa on kaksi eesnimiä ja perekona. Nimi siis, Mihin minä siihen kirjoitan?
Õpetaja: Nimi, Jos se voleava, että on ensi nimi,
Õpetaja: kun minä taakse täällä tiista, verkut oli siis minua. Teen missä muotin. Mitä
Õpetaja: niin, Control D ja siellä yhä? Roses on kaksi verko? No, Control T, Control. Kaks Raja Beregonnan nimi.
Õpetaja: Ja nyt on meillä pohjoisma Tabel Rida, Yksi,
Õpetaja: Yksi ver. Kaksi visualis on ensinnä peräkökunnan nimi.
Õpetaja: Kun minä nyt taakse päriseltä. Tehokka siis, rain dyr näköisiä alla kante
Õpetaja: H, Neljä Ja
Õpetaja: siis kun kootin mittasi, että minä tahan nyt tehdä siellä Rain tyyrissä. Missä minä tekemään
Õpetaja: kuitenkaan saa tehdä juuri tämän?
Õpetaja: No, se Siinä on Rita. Ykkän ja
Õpetaja: frontispetsialistit. Kus ne nyt ovat.
Õpetaja: Okei, Aus, aus muitakin. Älkää, älkää sen ikään kuin
Õpetaja: Minä olen uusi alka ja Ajakemmin palon ei Meitä ovat yksityistämällä.
Õpetaja: Yksi Riitä Juuri tämä.
Õpetaja: Okei, vaikka panemme nyt siellä kirja, joka kuitenkin savyhärää juurta
Õpetaja: minä olen kirjoittanut Tr Miss Realä Vasakkopuolueen.
Õpetaja: Kun minä kirjoitan Thr Cia Tr Röineä tr mininä plus
Õpetaja: ja. Siinä on david Raaka Minä. Itse asiassa kirjoittaisin ihan Rain Saksa Stubbligaateja panna tuli, mutta ei ole dublerita.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleeko täpset selin asiakas sellainen asialla? Siellä otsaan minä, koira Vajoittain kontrollilla tee
Õpetaja: ilmisellä realla, Kun te kunagi me too tritania selekteeritte ja tuubelta, että kopitte. Tehke niimoodi Vetkää niitä Rea. Vai vetkää? Ole reaa. Vahetus
Õpetaja: nyt. Dubleeritsi täällä pirakei
Õpetaja: missään selkeä saksin. Käy jopa nimeltä, että
Õpetaja: kun se kurssari liiku, kuitenkin. Minä tein Keyboardin kanssa on se, että nultakaan, kun mässän siellä Ja kai nyt kuumata vaan En
Õpetaja: nuola. Kallat olemaan Control D. No hyvä, teemme versan keikkain ja palan siihen. Ja juko jukujuan annetun laps,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa okei. No, sinne porterit ja Esson juurensa aikaa prinsiipistissä saattaa olla visuaaliset.
Õpetaja: Meidän klientimme ovat ara tehty tulevat esille. Nämä Se input
Õpetaja: imp Siellä ensimmäiseen mailiin tavallinen input
Õpetaja: on tyypit. Tekstit valkea. Meillä on nyt yhä täkiga
Õpetaja: ulatus. Tämä on seison atribuutit. Kun käsitsi, se kirjoitetaan. Tyyppisiä Tekst.
Õpetaja: No, missä olemaan?
Õpetaja: Okei, tämmöisellä Meaningfoliks ka. Panemme siihen, että H. Neljä ja panemme lisää. Uusi Te meni
Õpetaja: Ja nyt Panama Siski juurde Jopa Panama It.
Õpetaja: Ei tea, Me taho Mötsät panna siijaa. Okei, me panemme. Teemme näkyinokoira pitemmän.
Õpetaja: Panemme siihen kasteja, Etttäkää minkään siltin missen kastin Seispäin käima.
Õpetaja: Minä kirjoitan siia. Level Tason Välillä saa
Õpetaja: nimi arvoisa. Kirjoitetaan.
Õpetaja: Kirjoitetaan rainainen olettamaan, että siellä. Tulee Siis ma ei tea, minkä majis Sattumatta Starto.
Õpetaja: Teemme nykäs kaistikkeesta nyt. Missä Leibliga on? Vaan Että se kast on meillä olemassa. Se on se osa siinä.
Õpetaja: Me kunagi tahaksimme Programmilliset saataisiin sisu kättä. Siis on meillä vajaa minkit pitäjäpunkteja. Me saamme viitata just sellelillä kasteilla. Varastettu Meillä on Braxin Label Ace nimi. Ja Me Teemme siellä juuri peräkoinan Nimiä Onkin vanunsain Ja
Õpetaja: siis lopuksi meillä on programmilliset. Saan viitata Näillä kaistilla onkin se Id.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa Kysyn nyt, Minkä sellaisen muuttoja?
Õpetaja: Siltikkänä. Missä olla siltikkänä? Missä viittaa Bs nimellä Miksi olla siellä? Silti nimi.
Õpetaja: Niin sanotaan silti. Kylköpannaan, että minä saisimme hillemselällä viitata
Õpetaja: nimisissä. Kun sisuvi voi olla este kielellä, siis kooti kirjoitetakseen alat ingliskielä siis minä panen siia.
Õpetaja: First Name ja Camel Case.
Õpetaja: Aha, se On ihan koht, kus koiraa
Õpetaja: valitettavia itse teoriamateriaaleja, joissa on tietenkin olemassa vylässään
Õpetaja: Naming Conventions ja Vad Naming Conventions Coat formating Best practices
Õpetaja: saattoi Parasta hiljan. Vaata, että sellainen nimi
Õpetaja: Arvoisa minulla on editinen. Ilmeisesti nimälle
Õpetaja: käsi pistikesi uutisen kurssuista leiti vaadata, mitä tehdään.
Õpetaja: Monet ihmiset ovat mitä Materiaalit tulevat ripurata, kun taakse hakataan veits uudestaan. Veikkaan essyä ja suuremmat eivät taisi aika rauhallikomman temppua
Õpetaja: kun kaasasen Below Your level pikemminkin teoreettinen Ja Ball Tai itse asiassa tekeväisi.
Õpetaja: Rääkisimme sellaista, että on erinevat kirjavisiit
Õpetaja: Camel Case No, paskalista. Kunagi tuli paskaloon se, että edistetään nämä teatut Kootiliikkuttaa mitme sõnallisia asioita.
Õpetaja: Nimetän, että oleksi silmaanvoima, eli karu saata, että mito sana, vaikka siellä on niissä tinkimukset, että se ei saa, kirjoittaa tyikkuttinsa vanna, niin saa panna. My Glass
Õpetaja: on se, että ensimmäinen tähtä alkavat jopa suuret Kaikki Tähtä on erotettu. Suuret
Õpetaja: näyttää, että Lower Case Camel Case no Calculate. Senat ovat eräältäneet suuren tähekä esimen tähtää Alkan päiksä Tähänkään Lower Camel Case Upper Camel Case
Õpetaja: Sneakes synu eräältäkseen. Ala Gripsu, joka
Õpetaja: suurta lähteätäkään. Pikkasen vei guysvaltainen ja.
Õpetaja: Ja kebab. Case Qr Case Pecam On kebab case. On Grill varas
Õpetaja: Sinänsä mutta on se että on sitä kriipsuttu, vaan sitä. Kriips, sana.
Õpetaja: Suurt liitän. Meillä soida meil Siin se silkkänä
Õpetaja: traditsiooniliset oleskit. Siis Lower Camel Case First Name,
Õpetaja: Arvoisa puhemies.
Õpetaja: Arvoisa
Õpetaja: joskaan mitenkään koskaan.
Õpetaja: No, tämä vain tuntuu. Että teillä on vaja vastakkaiskukupärkiä. Minä panen Zoomi panen stopin päälle että taustalla. Kun Saksa
Õpetaja: stop Shervin kapannaa. Ajatke siis meillä. Soita.